Bell Gibson was a happy young Australian
she lived in Perth and she loved
skateboarding but in 2009 Beldon that
she had brain cancer and four months to
live two months of chemo and
radiotherapy had no effect but Bell was
determined she'd been a fighter her
whole life from age six she had a cook
for her brother who had autism and her
mother had multiple sclerosis her father
was out of the picture so Belle fought
with exercise with meditation and by
ditching meat for fruit and vegetables
and she made a complete recovery Bell
story went viral it was tweeted blogged
about shared and reach millions of
people it showed the benefits of
shunning traditional medicine for diet
and exercise in August 2013 Bell
launched a healthy eating app the whole
pantry downloaded 200,000 times in the
first month but Bell's story was a lie
Bell never had cancer people shared a
story without ever checking if it was
true this is a classic example of
confirmation bias we accept a story on
critically if it confirms what we'd like
to be true and we reject any story that
contradicts it how often do we see this
in the stories that we share and we
ignore in politics in business and
health advice the oxford dictionaries
word of 2016 was post truth and the
recognition that we now live in a post
truth world has led to a much needed
emphasis on checking the facts but the
punch line of my talk is that just
checking the facts is not enough even if
Bell's story were true it would be just
as irrelevant why well let's look at one
of the most fundamental techniques in
statistics
it's called Bayesian inference and the
very simple version is this
we care about does the data support the
theory does the data increase our belief
that the theory is true but instead we
end up asking is the data consistent
with the theory but being consistent
with the theory does not mean that the
data supports the theory why because of
a crucial but forgotten third term the
data could also be consistent with rival
theories but due to confirmation bias we
never consider the rival theories
because we're so protective of our own
pet theory now let's look at this
football story well we care about does
Bell story support the theory that diet
cures cancer but instead we end up
asking is Bell story consistent with
diet curing cancer and the answer is yes
if diet did cure cancer we'd see stories
like bells but even if diet did not cure
cancer we'd still see stories like
Bell's a single story in which a patient
apparently self cured just due to being
misdiagnosed in the first place just
like even if smoking was bad for your
health
you'd still see one smoker who lived
into a hundred just like even if
education was good for your income you'd
still see one multi-millionaire who
didn't go to university
so the biggest problem with belt story
is not that it was false it's that it's
only one story there might be thousands
of other stories where diet alone failed
but we never hear about them we share
the outlier cases because they are new
and therefore they are news we never
share the ordinary cases they're too
ordinary that they're what normally
happens and that's the true 99% that we
ignore just like in society you can't
just listen to the 1% the outliers and
ignore the 99% the ordinary because
that's the second example of
confirmation bias we accept a fact as
data the biggest problem is not that we
live in a post truth world it's that we
live in a post data world we prefer a
single story to tons of data now stories
are powerful they're feathered they
bring it to life they tell you to stop
every talk with the story I did but a
single story is meaningless and
misleading unless it's backed up by
large-scale data but even if we had
large-scale data that might still not be
enough because it could still be
consistent with rival theories let me
explain a classic study by psychologist
Peter wastin gives you a set of three
numbers and asked you to think of the
rule that generated that so if you were
given two four six
what's the rule well most people would
think it's successive even numbers how
would you test it well you propose other
sets of successive even numbers 4 6 8 or
12 14 16 and peter would say these sets
also work but knowing that these sets
also work knowing that perhaps hundreds
of sets of successive even numbers also
work tells you nothing because this is
still consistent with rival theories
perhaps the rule is any fee even numbers
or any fee increasing numbers and that's
the third example of confirmation bias
accepting data as evidence even if it's
consistent with rival theories data is
just a collection of facts evidence is
data that supports one theory and rules
out others so the best way to support
your theory is actually to try to
disprove it to play devil's advocate so
test something like four twelve twenty
six well if you got a yes to that that
would disprove your theory of successive
even numbers yet this test is powerful
because if you got a no it would rule
out any three even numbers and any three
increasing numbers it would rule out the
rival theories but not rule out yours
but most people are too afraid of
testing the four 12:26
because they don't want to get a yes and
prove their pet theory to be wrong right
confirmation bias is not only about
failing to search for a new data but
it's also about misinterpreting data
once you receive this and this applies
outside the lab to important real world
problems
indeed Thomas Edison famously said I
have not failed I have found 10,000 ways
that won't work finding out the out that
you're got is the only way to find out
what's right say your university
admissions director and your theories
the only students with good grades from
rich families do well so you only let in
such students and they do well but
that's not so consistent with a rival
theory perhaps all students with good
grades do well rich or poor but you
never test that theory because you never
let in poor students because you don't
want to be proven wrong so what have we
learned a story is not fair
because it may not be true a fact is not
data it may not be representative if
it's only one data point and data is not
evidence it may not be supportive if
it's consistent with rival theories so
what do you do when you're at the
inflection points of life deciding on a
strategy for your business a parenting
technique for your child or a regimen
for your health how do you ensure that
you don't have a story but you have
evidence let me give you three tips the
first is to actively seek other
viewpoints read and listen to people you
flagrantly disagree with 90% of what
they say may be wrong in your view but
what if 10% is right as Aristotle said
the mark of an educated man is the
ability to entertain a thought without
necessarily accepting it surround
yourself with people who challenge you
and create a culture that actively
encourages dissent some banks suffered
from groupthink where staff were too
afraid to challenge management's lending
decisions contributing to the financial
crisis in a meeting appoint someone to
be devil's advocate against your pet
idea and don't just hear another
viewpoint listen to it as well as
psychologist Stephen cobby said listen
with the intent to understand not the
intent to reply a dissenting viewpoint
is something to learn from not to argue
against which takes us to the other
forgotten terms in Bayesian influence
because data allows you to learn but
learning is only relative to a starting
point if you started with complete
certainty that your pet theory must be
true then your view won't change
regardless of what data that you see
only if you are truly open to the
possibility of being wrong
can you ever learn as Leo Tolstoy wrote
the most difficult subjects can be
explained to the most slow-witted man if
he has not formed any idea of them
already but the simplest thing cannot be
made clear to the most intelligent man
if he is firmly persuaded that he knows
already tip number two is listen to
experts now that has the most unpopular
advice that I could give you British
politician Michael Gove famously said
that people in this country have had
enough of experts a recent poll showed
that more people would trust their
hairdresser all the man on the street
then they would leaders of businesses
the health service and even charities so
we respect a teeth whitening formula
discovered by a mum or we listened to an
actresses view on vaccinations we like
people who tell it like it is you go
where they got and we call them
authentic but God feel can only get you
so far
God feel would tell you never to give
water to a baby with diarrhea because it
would just flow out the other end
expertise tells you otherwise you'd
never trust your surgery to the man on
the street you'd want an expert who
spent years doing surgery and knows the
best techniques but that should apply to
every major decision politics business
health advice require expertise just
like surgery so then why are experts so
mistrusted well one reason is they're
seen as out of touch a millionaire CEO
couldn't possibly speak for the man on
the street but true expertise is found
on evidence and evidence stands up for
the man on the street and against the
elites because evidence forces you to
prove it
evidence prevents the elites from
imposing their own view with
a second reason why experts are not
trusted is that different experts say
different things for every expert who
claimed that leaving the EU would be bad
for Britain another expert claimed it
would be good right half of these
so-called experts will be wrong and I
have to admit that most papers written
by experts are wrong or at best make
claims that the evidence doesn't
actually support so we can't just take
an experts word for it in November 2016
a study on executive pay hit national
headlines even though none of the
newspapers who covered the study had
even seen the study it wasn't even out
yet they just took the author's word for
it just like with bail nor does it mean
that we can just handpick any study that
happens to support our viewpoint that
would again be confirmation by us nor
does it mean that if seven studies show
a and three show B that a must be true
what matters is the quality and not the
quantity of expertise so we should do
two things first we should critically
examine the credentials of an authors of
the authors just like you'd critically
examine the credentials of a potential
surgeon are they truly experts in the
matter or do they have a vested interest
second we should pay particular
attention to papers published in the top
academic journals now academics are
often accused of being detached from the
real world but this detachment gives you
years to spend on a study to really nail
down a result to rule out those rival
theories and a distinguished correlation
from causation and academic journals
involve peer review where a paper is
rigorously scrutinized by the world's
leading minds the better the journal the
higher the standard the most elite
journals reject 95% of papers now
academic evidence is not everything
real-world experience is critical also
and and peer review is not perfect
mistakes are made but it's better to go
with something checked than something
unchecked if we latch on to a study
because we like the findings without
considering who it's by or whether it's
even been vetted there is a massive
chance that that study is misleading and
those of us who claim to be experts
should recognize the limitations of our
analysis very rarely is it possible to
prove or predict something with
certainty yet it's so tempting to make a
sweeping unqualified statement it's
easier to turn into a headline or to be
tweeted in 140 characters but even
evidence may not be proof it may not be
Universal it may not apply in every
setting so don't say Redwine causes
longer life when the evidence is only
that red wine is correlated with longer
life and only then in people who
exercise as well tip number three is
pause before sharing anything the
Hippocratic oath says first do no harm
what we share is potentially contagious
so be very careful about what we spread
our goal should not be to get likes or
retweets otherwise we only share the
consensus we don't challenge anyone's
thinking otherwise we only share what
sounds good
regardless of whether it's evidence
instead we should ask the following if
it's a story is it true if it's true is
it backed up by large-scale evidence if
it is who's that by what are their
credentials is it published how rigorous
is the journal and ask yourself the
million-dollar question
if the same study was written by the
same authors with the same credentials
but found the opposite results would you
still be willing to believe it and to
share it
treating any problem a nation's economic
problem or an individual's health
problem is difficult so you must ensure
that we have the very best evidence to
guide us only if it's true can it be
found only if it's representative can it
be data only if it's supportive can it
be evidence and only with evidence
can we move from a post truth world to a
pro truth world